this episode was made possible by
Skillshare home to over 20,000 classes
that could help teach you a new life
skill
[Music]
imagine yourself 50 or 60 years from now
lying on your deathbed surrounded by
friends and family or just dogs if
people aren't your thing you've lived a
good life had some laughs eaten a bunch
of tacos maybe even raised some kids or
well trained parrots it's time for you
to go you take your last breath
sike got you guys not dead yet your
family laughs you take your real last
breath and everything fades out what
happens next well you'd better hope your
loved ones clear out of the room pretty
quickly because things are about to get
weird there's a period of about 4 to 6
minutes during what you're considered
clinically dead this means that while
your heart is no longer pumping blood
and you've stopped breathing
your organs continue to function and
there may be enough oxygen left in the
brain to revive you without too much
permanent damage after these few short
minutes are up your organs shut down and
you experience biological death at which
point you are well and truly dead with
no hope of revival this is when things
get unpleasant after biological death
your muscles will relax
all of them which will cause your bowels
to empty after about 12 hours your skin
will start to lose its color as blood
pools at the lower points of the body
causing red and purple bruising at some
point before this your body will
experience rigor mortis a stiffening of
all the muscles caused by calcium
leaking into the muscle cells if you've
ever seen a dead deer on the side of the
road with its legs sticking straight out
that's rigor mortis once the bacteria in
your gastrointestinal tract eat through
your abdominal organs you're going to
start to smell really bad this is called
putrefaction if your body is anywhere
out in the wild the horrible smell will
attract insects which will begin to
consume your now rotting corpse these
little guys are efficient especially
maggots and blowflies which can consume
60% of the body's tissue in just a few
weeks hopefully you died someplace nice
like a hospital so your disembodied
ghost doesn't have to watch all these
horrible things happen to your body
speaking of ghosts what happens to the
part of you that's not physical is there
even such a thing many cultures and
religions believe in the idea of a soul
or a spirit or some form of incorporeal
manifestation of your conscious self
separate from the physical body to keep
things simple we'll use the word soul to
represent all these terms there are lots
of fascinating ideas about what happened
to this sole it would take way too long
to cover them all so we'll just look at
three common perspectives Christians
largely believe that depending on how
you lived your life your soul will be
sent either to eternal paradise with God
in heaven or to eternal torment in hell
this belief varies by denomination with
some people believing that you just need
to be baptized to go to heaven some
claiming that you have to do good works
while you're alive and still others
believing that hell doesn't exist at all
statistically about 31% of all humans on
earth identify as Christian and
therefore likely believe some variant of
the heaven or hell idea the next largest
group by number of adherents is Islam
which accounts for 23 percent of the
global population Islam shares many
similarities with Christianity or vice
versa
depending on how you want to look at it
they're both Abrahamic religions and
share similar perspectives on much of
their faith they do differ somewhat in
terms of beliefs about the afterlife
many Muslims believe that after you die
your soul remains with your body in your
grave where you'll receive visions of
your fate until one day Allah raises all
the dead from their graves to judge all
the souls and send them either to
paradise or to hell
whereas many Christians believe their
souls are transported instantly to their
eternal fate Muslims got the short end
of the stick and have to stew for a bit
in their dead bodies on the bright side
that means more time before you have to
go to hell if you were naughty of course
this is only one of several Islamic
interpretations of the process of death
another perspective on death comes from
the Buddhists Buddhism asserts that life
is cyclical when you die your spirit is
reincarnated into a new body which could
be anything from another human to an
insect this process then repeats over
and over and over again until the soul
achieves enlightenment when a soul
reaches enlightenment they will leave
behind their mortal coil and reach
nirvana which is seen as an
incomprehensible indescribable and
inconceivable place the idea of
reincarnation is very appealing to a lot
of people including many Westerners who
were raised Christian it's not hard to
see why the idea of death is scary and
despite all of our many explanations of
what may happen after death we can't be
certain the Buddhist idea that we could
come back and live many more lives is
very comforting ok we've looked at a few
religious explanations for what happens
after death but what about for those of
us who don't identify as religious well
if we're looking strictly at natural
explanations for biological functions
it's most likely that nothing happens
after death your consciousness is tied
to your brain and when your brain ceases
to function you cease to exist
have been Studies on the phenomenon of
so-called near-death experiences but
obviously the results of these studies
are inherently flawed since the
responses have to come from someone
whose brain was literally shutting down
that being said the results are
interesting and worth noting in some
instances people who have been brought
back from the brink of death reported
walking towards a bright light which
many religious people take to mean
ascending towards heaven other people
report nothing at all they were awake
then it was like they fell into a
dreamless sleep and woke up again some
things many reports of near-death
experiences have in common is the
sensation of floating upwards out of
your body or seeing old friends or
relatives or watching scenes from your
life flash before your eyes while
medical experts have many hypotheses for
why exactly some people have these
near-death experiences there's not
really a sure answer yet scientists are
fairly certain these experiences are
just the spasms of a dying brain
flooding your nervous system with
chemicals in a losing battle against
death but they still need a lot more
data to figure out the finer details of
what occurs in the moments before we die
for a lot of people who don't believe in
the afterlife and even for many who do
death can be really scary one good quote
from Mark Twain might help a little he
said I do not fear death I had been dead
for billions and billions of years
before I was born and had not suffered
the slightest inconvenience from it so
whatever you believe live your life in a
way that makes you happy makes others
remember you fondly and in general just
be the best version of you you can be
one way to improve yourself is by
learning new skills which is why I
always recommend checking out Skillshare
Skillshare is an online learning
community for creators with over 20,000
classes and everything from photography
to graphic design to productivity
marketing fine art and more I love
Skillshare because any time I'm bored I
can just put on a class and learn
something worthwhile a premium
membership gives you unlimited access to
high-quality classes on useful topics so
you can improve your skills unlock new
opportunities and do the work you love
I'm actually working on my own intro to
photography course I'm not going to give
you an estimate of when it'll be done
because it's taking much longer than I
expected but it'll be available for you
to watch at some point in the near
future join the millions of students
already learning on Skillshare today
with a special offer just for you guys
get two months of Skillshare completely
free to start learning amazing new
skills today visit skill share by
following the link below
[Music]